until people feel your message until  people get some excitement from until  you make them feel something good or bad  they're never going to buy from you  they're never going to want to interact  with you they're going to ignore you  you have to learn to inject  passion and emotion into your tweets and  this shouldn't be hard  just think about who you are and that  one word that you stand for  everything you create should make you  feel something  if you're putting out a facebook post an  instagram picture a twitter post if it  doesn't make you feel something if it  doesn't get your heart beating  don't post it  that's the test  you